we've recently had new reports coming
out saying that the m1x max
could be limited to only 32 gigabytes of
ram
contradicting previous reports and
expectations
of up to 64 gigabytes of ram for apple's
upcoming pro macbooks
and while many people are now
disappointed saying things like the m1x
max
won't really be pro if they are limited
to just 32 gigabytes of ram
after looking over our previous tests
and doing some
in-depth research i came to the
conclusion that these upcoming macs
don't actually need 64 gigabytes of ram
for three reasons and even if they do
end up giving us a 64 gigabyte option i
won't be buying it
anyways and you shouldn't either let me
explain
exactly why as far back as i can
remember
computer enthusiasts have been buying
the most ram that we can
or at least the most ram that we can
afford i remember
my first serious 4k video editing
computer 10 years ago
and me shelling out a ton of money to
get myself
32 gigabytes of ram most likely the same
amount that the m1x will have
in 2021 at the time i was building
a custom video editing pc designed to
cut through 4k footage
back when many people were still editing
720p
let me just say that i have always loved
high quality video
back in the day when most people were
editing across multiple slow spinning
hard drives
running out of ram was a disaster and if
that happened
most systems would lock up messing up
your work 32 gigs of ram
was the optimal amount back then but due
to poor software optimization
actually editing 4k video ended up being
a nightmare
and i ended up selling it and buying a
trash can mac pro
which had weaker hardware and only half
the ram
but thanks to macos and final cut pro
the system ran
laps around my custom water cooled
windows pc
with the best ssd and the best graphics
card on the market
and an overclocked extreme intel
processor
and it wasn't only because of mac
specific software a year or so later i
tested what the optimal amount of ram
was for video editing
using the same hardware and the same
inefficient premiere pro
and the really tough video export was
basically just as fast
with 16 gigs of ram and mac os as it was
with 32 gigs of ram
in windows and unlike today back then
premiere
was way more optimized for windows of
course since then windows has gotten a
lot better and running at a ram doesn't
mean your computer will just blue screen
of death
or cause apps to lock up and close but
the software efficiency difference is
still
there just over a year ago we basically
revisited that same comparison and built
a custom pc
that smoked our new mac pro in terms of
hardware
using 32 threadripper cores which
resulted in an embarrassing amount of
extra cpu performance
and an nvidia graphics card that has
over 50 percent
more raw power with a ton of coda cores
and about double the gaming performance
as well as pci express 4 ssd that was
smoking fast but even with that in most
tasks the weaker mac pro was still
faster
like in regular 4k editing and an even
bigger difference
in the much more difficult h.265 and
this is all with premiere pro
that we're not talking about final cut
here with that in the very optimized
davinci resolve
the real world graphics raw power for
video
and rendering was somehow the same what
all of this shows
is how important software optimization
and efficiency
really is and that mac os works very
well with less powerful hardware and
less ram
even with cross platform software but
what about
what we're talking about here where you
have two macs
both running the same operating system
the older generation with 64
gigabytes of ram and the other newer
more powerful
m1x mac being limited to just 32
gigabytes of ram
and what will that mean for real-world
performance
well i think you'll be surprised because
on top of all that software optimization
we just talked about
apple leveled up their performance and
efficiency with their apple silicon
chips
and 32 gigs of ram will perform the same
or better
than 64 gigabytes of ram with an intel
machine
and with that you will save 400 compared
to last year
let me explain exactly why and how when
apple announced their m1 chip they put a
huge
emphasis on the unified memory
architecture meaning the memory is right
there
next to the processor and the graphics
this is not only important for speed
but also for performance and efficiency
and how much ram you need
in most laptops that use integrated
graphics the graphics has to use
ram that is shared with the cpu just
like with the m1
but because the ram has a lot more
latency
and it has to be sent and controlled by
the cpu it takes much longer to send
data back and forth
compared to apple silicon with that
apple built in
even faster specialized tile memory and
processing
to minimize the need to use system
memory even though the latency is much
lower than
intel based systems because of this even
though the m1 air's raw graphics
performance
wasn't that much faster than latest
intel processors
in real world use the m1 ends up being
much faster
than the raw performance would have you
expect and this
is using non-optimized software when you
look at partially optimized software
like davinci resolve
the difference grows even further now
this only shows
performance not the optimal amount of
ram but as you can see working with
eight gigs of ram and integrated
graphics is really slow
because of bandwidth and that total
amount but because apple's unified
memory is so
fast tasks don't need to keep data in
the ram for as long and when it needs to
be cleared out it can clear much faster
as well
an antec took a deep dive into apple m1
in its architecture and was shocked by
the memory performance
instead of dual channel memory with
intel consumer chips
apple's m1 runs an 8-channel memory
resulting
in very high bandwidth and having so
many channels means much faster speed
for certain workloads as we've shown off
when we compared a dual channel ram imac
quad channel imac pro and 6 channel mac
pro the imac pro was faster for
bandwidth limited photo work
even though its ram was slower and it
only had 32 gigs of ram instead of 64
as well as an older slower a core
processor instead of a new
much faster 10 core because of the super
fast ram and 8 gigabyte m1 chip
smokes the latest 5k imac with way more
cpu and gpu performance
apple's 8 gig of ram is even faster than
16 gigs ram on that imac
showing you that you no longer need a
high amount of ram to get proper speeds
and anantech also showed off that
even a single core can reach 59
gigabytes a second which is crazy
intel's latest 11gen chips reach only
just over half the performance at 34.5
gigabytes a second
and that is after a big jump with big
improvements
from the 10th generation and keep in
mind apple's only macbook
that offers 64 gigabytes of ram has
memory significantly slower than that
and it used to smoke 13-inch models
based on sheer power
but now efficiency is starting to take
over and a
dollar eight gig macbook air is almost
as fast as a 4
000 macbook with four times the amount
of ram
in tasks that are really ram limited and
with programs that
aren't yet optimized and also keep in
mind that mac os
itself takes up a good three to four
gigs
of that eight gigs of ram and that
brings you back
to the main topic of 32 gigs of ram
versus 64
in the upcoming m1x and why having 64
gigs
doesn't matter we've done a lot of
testing in the past between
32 gigs of ram and 64 gigs of ram and
both macbook pros and imacs
and in almost every single test having
64 gigs of ram didn't do much of
anything and that is
intel compared to intel with slower
speeds and less efficiency
so when it came time to give suggestions
on how much ram to buy for macbooks
i suggested 32 gigs of ram to almost
everybody
even those that might run multiple
productivity tests and many
web browsing tabs and you've already
seen just how much more efficient
apple's unified ram is compared to
regular ram with an intel based mac and
how much faster it is at being used and
cleared for new
tests and based on our testing 8 gigs of
unified ram performs
more like 16 gigs of regular ram and 16
gigs performs more like 32 gigs
the same thing will go for 32 gigs of
unified memory in the m1x
acting similar to 64 gigs of ram but
without costing you
that extra 400 that's not only because
of sheer speed but hardware and software
design that apple has made
it is now showing developers how to do
simple optimizations for
that significantly cut down on ram usage
with apple silicon max
in one example cutting ram usage from
2.16 gigs down to 810 megabytes
and saving an additional 216 megabytes
by not needing duplicate copies these
are the kind of hardware changes that
make the m1x
no longer need 64 gigs of ram or if
you're somebody that previously bought
32 gigs as i suggested
even 16 gigs will be plenty and as
you've seen with the current m1 max
systems that previously offered 32 gigs
now only come with 16
and they perform much better because mac
os
is so efficient you never get a crash if
you hit your ram limit
but instead less important tasks will be
saved to the ssd
in the form of swap memory now i know
swap has a bad rap since people have
paid
way more attention to ram and swap after
the m1 came out
with less total ram available but swap
works wonders by virtually giving you
more ram from your ssd
in my ultimate ram stress test only once
i loaded up a ton of pro programs and a
bunch of safari and chrome tabs
did i notice that 8 gigs of ram was
starting to run out and web pages had to
be reloaded
from the ssd but surprisingly that still
happened very fast that is because
with the m1 max apple no longer puts in
much worse ssds and their cheaper macs
but really fast ones across the board
and that brings me to my last reason
i believe that the m1x max will finally
have much faster storage
than the 2.5 to 3 000 megabyte per
second ssds that have lived in the best
mac
since around 2016. apple is now
finally putting these ssds into the base
max
while the m1 actually supports pci
express 4
which is what's required to break that
performance ceiling
which we used in our latest custom pc
and apple
isn't currently using that pci express 4
for the ssds or for
graphics like you typically would
because the m1 has built-in graphics
into the soc
so my thought is since the gaming pc
express 4
now they are no longer limited by
version 3 and they can finally put in
faster ssds
and putting those into their more
expensive pro line would make a lot of
sense
it would once again differentiate speeds
between the cheaper m1 max and the m1x
max
and in the case where you might need to
use swap
memory you would get speeds that are
roughly two to four
times faster because of the ssd
increases and
latency improvements this is why the m1x
macbooks don't need 64 gigabytes of ram
and even if apple offers it i personally
will not be buying it and i will not be
suggesting it
now of course we will be testing it out
we'll show you guys the differences if
you guys want to see that click that
circle above to subscribe
and that will help us reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of the year
that is our goal we would appreciate it
check out one of those great videos
right over there this one max and i will
see you
in the next video
[Music]
you